Alexandria Casa Cortez is not a genius
doesn't know a lot but what she lacks in
impressive quality she makes up for with
pure aggression and moxie and as a
result she never and her friends now
dominate and to some extent control the
Democratic Party they're the ones
pushing impeachment corrupt president
who violates his Olson office must and
will be impeached
it is absolutely time to start formal
impeachment proceedings what he has
admitted to is already impeachable
regardless of future developments I know
it's time it's been time we must impeach
this lawless president well Congress
ordered shoot celeb she's a charmer
the last one you saw there is selling
impeached and mother-effer t-shirts
online now that of course echoes a
promise she made well before the Ukraine
controversy even existed ned brian is
the founder of american majority he
joins us tonight so Ned you know for the
first I would say couple months that the
squad became prominent it was a
Republican talking point to say for
obvious reasons that they're really in
charge of the Democratic Party but it's
starting to kind of seem true oh
absolutely I think with every passing
day Nancy Pelosi is really speaker and
name only the inmates have taken over
the asylum which isn't really that
surprising Tucker the parasitic far-left
has been eating the democratic party
from within for years and now it's
coming to the surface and you're right
they're an amazing blend of ignorance
and petulance and stupidity and hatred I
mean the fact that they're selling
shirts for 1999 to which I say knock
yourselves out
since Nancy Pelosi announced impeachment
Trump has raised 13 million for his
reelect but then you have Adam Schiff
out there deciding that the chairmanship
of the House Intel committee is now a
platform for parity it's pretty amazing
to watch that the thing that's crazy to
me is Dems are willing to destroy all of
these norms because orange man bad if
you think about what's taking place over
the last 2 and 1/2 years Russia gate
collusion Ukraine gate all of this stuff
it's about one thing talker it's about
policy differences they cannot
and the fact that they are not in power
and that Trump has a different approach
to governing not only domestically but
on foreign policy as well and so now
their new approach and all this we shall
impeach all things will impeach Kavanagh
will impeach Trump based off what
nothing policy differences so I got to
kind of wonder once these people take
full control formal control of the party
and that's only a cycle or two away but
you people like Adam Schiff really
believe they're gonna continue to run
committees I mean there's not a mr. Adam
Schiff no no the amazing part is if you
study history these revolutions have a
way of eating themselves just look at
the French Revolution and Robespierre so
I think they're gonna start to realize
this will eat that they'll start eating
each other but as you go down this path
I think they there it shows how to
arrange they are look at the impeachment
polls this week and the midst of all of
this hysteria about Ukraine gate
Politico morning consult only showed 36
36 percent of the American people
supporting impeachment of Trump and if
you get into the heartland might where I
grew up talker impeachment drops a
little low 20s and you start to think
about how stupid they are when you get
to these swing districts of Oklahoma v
and Illinois 14 which are real pick up
opportunities for the GOP in 2020
they're going to make those members
watch walk the impeachment plank and
lose the majority I really do think so
in 2020 if they continue to push this
because I think impeaching Trump is a
fool's errand being pushed by fools will
see that Ryan great to see you tonight
thanks so much for that
thanks talker